[Musique
] tout a commencé par un appel à l'aide et
a ralenti la marche parce qu'un seul
niveau atomique, une jeune femme dit que
les dirigeants autochtones de sa communauté ont
refusé de la laisser déposer une
plainte pour abus sexuel contre le principal suspect, nous
sommes tous tombés malades rapidement et  boulimiques
avec eux ces derniers mois plusieurs
femmes nous ont contacté pour dénoncer
les abus sexuels perpétrés sur les
jeunes indigènes Conrad à cause de cette
relance volatile ce qu'ils sont hors sujet ils
ont tendu la main par téléphone ou sur les réseaux sociaux
comme Facebook depuis un demi-million
Thomas et Emily ils  décrit leur
détresse et leur sentiment d'
impuissance le sujet aujourd'hui remercient la
planète Terre ils se sentent impuissants le
pic de massage 1000 un trafiquant criminel au
chef complet Mitch la pollution et un père
font de plus les trajets sont rapides surtout les
abus prétendument commis par des
leaders indigènes jeune adulte sous chimio Balaton  une
position autoritaire sous anesthésie les
américains souvent pour les femmes la justice est
refusée consommer de manière appropriée  quand
on se contente de connecter les services vieillissants la
pédophilie un phénomène si répandu
que les jeunes dirigeants se sentent dépassés
Oberman à ma délégation de la National
Basketball Association pour servir le général
janitrol
[Musique]
leurs histoires sont difficiles à entendre mais
leur détermination nous a ouvert la voie
pour comprendre leur sort  parfois cette
route est longue laver à minuta nam laisse
aux seuils et la Côte-Nord de Québec est à 12
heures de route de Montréal nous sommes venus ici pour
rencontrer une jeune femme qui dit que le chef de
la réserve l'a agressée sexuellement une
interdiction de publication ordonnée par le tribunal
nous empêche de  nommer son acceptation un poulet
de quoi de de elección de los de dooda
risquer l'apocalypticisme PAP chef Jamie
Soulja Stockton
taco Marcelo c'était l'année 2000 le
chef actuel Mike McKenzie si
le temps responsable de la jeune
actrice il avait 26 ans elle avait  vient de
fêter son 13e anniversaire creuser dur
car chuck testa Stallone dit-il
a duré plusieurs années sans que personne
n'intervienne  ing le harcelant Hagen Tazawa a
terriblement réussi 2006 aller Pastrana La
Silla machine leader civique Deng ne la
connaissait pas vraiment mais avait entendu dire qu'elle
était intimidée j'ai pas parlé de
Mestre g SE beaucoup c'est SSA allez donc Mike
McCann recherche à  la colina de PC el
Camas khawaja Reza
yup bon singe plus de participants de
Facebook et Edna Petrovna organocopper
radical eptas remarqué mon oreiller jaune
presse taco de kazuto découpage un oreiller
saddam imaginez opana pata pata nahi dawa
Pierce possédé Regina mahjong habiba
Kamado Nia le découpage pika Casa San
Jessica halète coup de sifflet lapa le chariot ha
ha ha Lopakhin mon orteil osti ha ha ha
se produit plus lourdement Pacific Alaniz ci-dessous
avait vécu une terrible tragédie avec sa
fille comprendre Olivia entrepreneur
la ville de mccain nitreux sur Televisa
pipi
cette année-là seulement cinq personnes se sont
suicidées ici que  a déclenché une enquête publique les
femmes ont lié le suicide dans leur
communauté à l'abus sexuel les gens n'ont pas
chanté pas donc ce produit chimique je le répare  n l'
incendie a mis un peu dénoté ce système l'a
rempli dans OC Sunnah wal comme à votre
goût un peu au fil des ans pourrait faire
dans ce rôle dans la communauté a grandi il a
décidé de se présenter comme chef
il a soutenu a massacré son intégrité
qui était trop pour  la jeune femme
qu'elle a appelée la police la police et
Mahajan Pavel paniquent a confisqué la
réponse de la cellule maman et c'est alors qu'elle
nous a appelés déconcertés il n'est pas avec les enfants les plus pauvres
contre réapprendre aux enfants la
communauté de lavage à minuta nam a sa
propre force de police indigène appelée le
ruisseau  qui ne voulait pas prendre la
plainte nous sommes allés parler au chef de la police
il ne voulait pas parler à la caméra
nous avons enregistré la conversation vierge
Frankie - minun La Salette
reportage sur le pastoralisme québécois je pense que l'
épopée Gallagher un chic Houston Salinas donc la  femme
tournée vers la subvention québécoise en fixant
petit pingouin Twitter Encino so Tampopo
8th Avenue tak la Spinoza Padma ose
comme quand les machettes Las pampas pop Carla
deposition  Pascal - hasta la bas ouais donc la
sénatrice Amanda un avocat a dû
intervenir pour que la police autochtone et
la cigale du Québec collaborent le
chef a finalement été inculpé
je digresse qz sur 6 à 8 donc je veux dire non
sachons juste Mike McKenzie donc
c'est  l'exemple a ma choppa
peu de temps après, il est retourné à son
travail, nous voulions parler au chef McKenzie
pour discuter des accusations qu'il nie
qu'il n'est jamais disponible mais c'est ce qu'il a
dit aux nouvelles locales
sailu démocrates, se sépare et notre
économie fonctionne ce  l'attitude désinvolte a
touché un nerf Attaque de mano personnelle du Maharaja
- Elena du chef yaku dit à Mensa
Macedon camino de cuerpo non Daniel a
séduit le manioc fessée un C +
Liepaja mandela famiiy est un
enfer phénoménal équipé d'un direct progressif vraiment
Duncan a les clés de la photo Tomas
Gonzales glaçage de  oreillers sur luzerne
début serré handicap avec le nom
nous a contacté pour dénoncer sa peine Oncle Léo
un ancien policier devenu
homme d'affaires et il va  elle avait appris que
son agresseur venait d'être honoré alors qu'il
assistait au séminaire de prévention du suicide
il avait reçu ce prix pour reconnaître
son rôle d'aide aux femmes à peine deux mois
après avoir été reconnu coupable de grossière indécence
elle laissa tomber la chambre au sous-sol
où son oncle agressait petit sérieusement
il il  noblement avez-vous fait
elle a utilisé un dessin similaire devant le tribunal ce
n'était pas facile l'affaire a été reportée
quatre fois mais la torture à chaque fois elle
dit pourtant elle a persévéré il n'est vraiment
pas le guidry pour remettre en question évaluer le
Kiska Shiva a créé Twitter à la dernière
minute  Leo a été déclaré coupable, il a
reçu une absolution conditionnelle et a
reçu l'ordre de faire un don de trois mille dollars
à des organismes de bienfaisance communautaires,
il a également été enregistré comme délinquant sexuel
.
il n'a rien fait Monica
comédie joue le temps j'ai volé le reste comme
vous le prédisez citrouille - il l'a fait - peut le
prendre un popu  lar visiter la barre de la légende du tennis nous
à d'autres femmes disent qu'elles ont été
agressées par Leo st.  Onge à l'époque où il
était policier dans la région,
Juwan a déposé une plainte auprès du
Bureau des enquêtes indépendantes du Québec,
elle dit que les abus se sont produits au poste de
police avec Melissa Futaba,
mais comme ils ont arrêté Elizabeth d'une
manière aprotique, il s'agit d'essayer Megan de le
démarrer  reconnaîtra le crédit d'
apprendre et il y a un an une autre chez les femmes
Chantal nous a raconté le double viol
auquel elle avait survécu impliquant la phrase Oh amor fedosova
tortue de lave une base de pyramide jouet mmm
Pattullo une deuxième entrée Aprilia l'
abondance de pâtes de Petrova y a livré des
applaudissements agressés  aucune accusation n'a été portée et
ils condamneront tout nie à ce
jour le plus visité la colonne de spécimens poly perte de de
la vaca
fatumak par la façon dont le
certificat d'honneur qui m'a été remis sur la
peine a été révoqué en juin dernier électrique
un chef de file de l'atomique  l'ancien
chef de la police nationale de la communauté des femmes
dit qu'elle se rend au palais de justice
qu'il avait été reconnu coupable d'
agression sexuelle sur cinq  femmes trois d'entre elles étaient des
enfants au moment de l'abus peoc
Amasya Batta Batta Batta est une adresse IP
vidéo etc tasse chaque semaine
Pacifica pénétration imaginaire
connectons un tigre est excuse le fait
pas de coca-cola
pendant 40 ans
Jean Palacios a pu abuser des femmes
et des enfants en toute impunité le vieil homme que
vous voyez ici aujourd'hui avait été un
dirigeant respecté un policier
conseiller politique un négociateur des droits ancestraux
pour la nation universitaire il semblait
tout avoir et à ce jour il dit qu'il n'est
pas coupable les femmes sont toutes des menteuses
cette histoire est remarquable en raison des
retards encourus plus de dix ans se sont
écoulés depuis que les premières plaintes ont été
déposées au verdict des retards que tous les
pauvres mais expliqués par aucun signe victime
vont cheok avril même nos plus pauvres une personne de Chris
Bosh Saddam à calico Hanapepe
dr  .  Damon Oliveira pesetas à zéro la
femme policier qui a commencé l'
enquête en 2005 ne peut pas l'expliquer
Michael exécution à l'étendue de Dunedin à
travers l'Oklahoma aucun poisson n'est venu
récemment étant donné le soutien habituel alors qui
est responsable des retards qu'ils
défendent l'enquête policière  le
fait que les victimes soient indigènes c'était une
attente terrible pour ces femmes
je vais laver c'était la première femme
à porter plainte avocat sur Maundy pants
un gestionnaire de cas Mont une clé Jericho
pasquese plus facile Panozzo Stano
équation V équipe tu plaisantes
balla balla  ligne de stress afin de
protéger les victimes d'agression sexuelle, les tribunaux
protègent normalement leur identité, mais
Nicole voulait donner un visage à Nia,
elle est victime de devenir une SI ellos dis
reconsidérer est nishijima
- Holly G de X est alpha le rêve sur
salmiak n'est pas final commercia amazon
Shui avec no dear Jesus j'avoue je souhaite que
ma division sexuelle en visit Jesus is the
paranormal this was in women tester une
communauté à cent kilomètres non  À l'ouest
de deux heures de route lexicales sur une
route forestière, l'épidémie s'adaptait à un nouvel
élève à tous les modes de vie
La mère de Nicole a insisté pour qu'elle prenne soin
de Jean-Paul II en tant que ses enfants pour faire
un prêt d'argent
Giada Gimenez tante Lindo Nelvana maman d'
accord
- Alexis woodland  est tombé sur un sabbat
vodka nous spécifions un épisode alors sur Nia les
points de suture ont duré cinq ans mobile
une monopalme Carmel Valley monopalmes Gypo
Gypo nageur et un fumiste une
fois qu'elle est devenue adulte Nikolas pour se
protéger
jusqu'au jour où il y a 10 ans, elle
traversait des mensonges
yesh était devenu un grand-père Judith
Takeda traitait un analyste san Alamo Elvis
L signifiait un discret je vais pas baccarat
Clavinova vision society set Bella food
lab douce épicée varma pour scheana elle n'est
pas responsable à l'esprit le fait que
c'était une femme policier et il est venu
oeuf en plus de celui qui a pris la
plainte pour le lien de confiance qui a
aidé à mettre fin au silence de la femme habituellement
réservé à une personne avant Sylvester
fa  mily qui moi le max ils font depuis longtemps
que la physiologie d'Aldama Bush est de connivence
parce qu'elle lui a dit qu'ils étaient plus de victimes
elle a alors réalisé que l'affaire était trop grosse
pour la police indigène ici laissez-moi
imaginer si pour voir il faut appeler la police
Maître nous appelons le  la police continue tout de suite de
rire il faut être patient pour que
certains
pays fassent leur distance magique jusqu'à quel point ma
ville globale d'un taureau endommage dans le
Pacifique depuis que ça va Groupama l'affaire a
été transférée au circuit de Québec
et a failli dérailler
le premier enquêteur  qui a rencontré Nicole
pense que c'était une vengeance politique
Kakuma pallidus c'est une agence agence la
mode est facile Salim Adel elle encercle
plusieurs services il a fallu un autre
enquêteur sq pour faire avancer l'affaire
six longues années se sont écoulées avant que des accusations ne
soient portées puis quatre ans au tribunal un
entier  année a été perdue dans les ajournements
demandés par l'avocat de la défense que
pendant tout le temps jean-paul Nia sheesh a travaillé
et pendant le procès a continué à
toucher son salaire
zecharia sitchin qqp sont tous sales
peu importants pour des cents une communauté
pas de stylo de mélange il définitivement de septembre
à l'automne 2016
Zamboni ashish est condamné à six ans
de prison une première pour un
leader autochtone dans une petite communauté soudée l'
agresseur est toujours un père d'un  ami
le fils d'un voisin un frère c'est
le cas ici chez les femmes qu'elle où on
tombe sur le chef c'est de la merde pour une
opération en ligne son acquisition d'Heidi
viens je ne pleurerai pas dans le monde le
chef a mentionné plus d'un accusé à
part le sien  frère un autre dirigeant
a également été accusé de viol Mac a déclaré être
un négociateur important des
droits ancestraux fin janvier il a plaidé
coupable d'agression sexuelle
complice avec Joe Cornish vient de se promener
dans le contexte loader ventre de porc
Lana Del Posto année un supérieur plutôt
puissant un  passion ou notre gorge Larry
Daley pasteur
Kiara's ferme kor khon kaen modestie la
pasión sur Jionni police exploit également
choisi et les communautés que nous servons  la
décision également favorable car le cycle se
déroule continuellement de manière festive et
continue d'être soutenu nous avons appris
après avoir été chez les femmes qu'elle que le
chef avait embauché Mac a dit si en tant que
négociateur
même si les accusations étaient connues et
l'enquête préliminaire avait déjà
eu lieu
Mac a dit  quel vain Giovanni Ashish sont
des figures presque mythiques pour le
gimmick edge allez sur Google Le Père Noël peut retourner
au camp évidemment dire un repas de vacances
et d'excellents produits chimiques pouvez-vous me voler
presque que Domecq a permis à Maggie de voir que ça
sonne revenir nœud où pourrait la
semaine du bain le  nouveau Grand chef de l'
allumage HCM est un jeune avocat représentant
les espoirs d'une nouvelle génération alors que lors d'une
tournée des communautés un jeune
lui a tendu la main tu ne peux pas vraiment
parler un populairement Lestat peut prendre soin
et attention à la tour noire la
pédophilie  et sœur de la communauté qui disent à
notre Père oui je veux dire ce mot en Iran
donc je vais elle une étude a confirmé l'
ampleur du problème plus  plus de la moitié de
tous les abus sexuels signalés sur une
période de cinq ans où sur les enfants de
moins de 14 ans les
autochtones croient que jusqu'à soixante-dix pour cent d'
entre eux ont été agressés sexuellement
imaginez 70 pour cent agressés à Montréal
ou à Québec ce serait une crise nationale
c'est  le secret le moins bien gardé que les femmes ne
veulent plus garder le silence mais les cas qui
prennent dix ans c'est décourageant est
généralement la réalité polka moins
on lui demande de choisir un jouet il trouve la seule
poupée dans la boite et la
tient toute la séance il a secoué la poupée
tout en décrivant ce qui lui est arrivé
son voisin le fils de la baby-sitter qui l'a
abusé sexuellement parfois le chien
subit le plus gros de son traumatisme  ça a commencé
en 2009 ici au bord de la rivière
allez dans les rires des gars Samantha
bonjour Julia - les taille-crayons surveillent son
fils avait 5 ans
jenny fait rage r  se souvient qu'un adolescent de
sa communauté l'a amené dans les bois le
long du chemin de sept îles
spécifications du signal alimentaire philipovna
était une prière et la facture douanière a
duré des mois
son fils a été agressé sexuellement par un
adolescent le fils de sa baby-sitter puis il
a dû quitter ses enfants  avec une
baby-sitter fournie par les services sociaux
de la communauté EMU elle était au
chevet de son plus jeune luttait contre une
maladie rare et dévastatrice - appuyé
notre cas sinistre Québec milles
m.  Costa - m.  Khan Khan desu ka
Victoria Nava de
retour à la maison tout en préparant le souper un
voisin lui dit que l'adolescente est partie
avec son fils Japon Kyoto Japon ecclesia
Murphy's Avenue il est revenu en révélant un
sombre secret des images pendant longtemps une
petite danse savoureuse pendant longtemps sur moi mon
cher toi '  j'ai dit qu'un DP surpasse le
style italique compact émérite est la
discectomie elle a dit qu'elle a appelé la
police indigène ce film pour déposer une
plainte
pas un pour le temps je suis une usine de cornée
vraiment des politiques sur vous passez une clé les
personnes âgées de Sarasota manquent Paso del Toro
Peter Sonya  Sankara a repoussé un
dernier avion de la police le plus modeste un
service de lave de volley discret pro dpdt nerf ammoniac
donc plus de sorte de vous
Altesses Hisako mais il est gardé par une
théière oh personne ne veut amener l'
enfant à l'hôpital pour le faire
examiner et à  recueillir des preuves que
Jenny lui apporte nous-mêmes après la
plainte forcée le médecin des urgences
prend note de ses voitures et demande
que des échantillons soient prélevés ce qu'on
appelle communément un kit de viol et Su  leiman Lamont
crayon
change la contrebande avec les développeurs, etc.
à ton père un nom populaire des
années
Standish aidé par lui
[Musique]
Elizabeth oh ouais les
téléphones portables sont d'aujourd'hui l'adolescent
est maintenant un jeune adulte il a un permis de
conduire et un permis d'armes à feu nous les avons
rencontrés pour lui poser quelques questions
il  ne voulait pas nous parler on ne peut pas le
nommer car au moment des
faits il était encore mineur et
protégé par les services de l'enfance
c'est Marvin un container Pakistan mr.
mica Shakti magista
confère alors appelez cela leur dévotion sur les
téléphones et un dollar aussi gigantesque dans mon
Java en secret est un indice pour Jenny le
gros problème est qu'il vit près de sa
maison oui Donna commue une famine sur West
aanava 'chez les femmes orignaux  les hommes optent pour l'
acrylique sur Van Andel de l'
usine de sécurité sapa Yolanda Panem est une
excuse phonologique éthiquement ridicule même Madonna
ne devrait utiliser que Caleb un alpha belge
au bout du rouleau
Jenny demande l'aide du psychologue
Daniel dicen un esquimau po o Muhammad bnx
ptl's the posters  d'un examen complet
Superjail d'accord
été région de Bakken le psychologue
prend le relais et demande des
explications officielles Kadhafi de cocora magazine
s'oppose à
van canto réintégrer pokhara légèreté mon
ennemi de retour sur le deuxième rapport de cotes j'ai
appelé l wa-ait correct Irma existait nous
ne pouvons pas révéler  un cours habituel populaire liturgique
mon bureau sans réserve la
société Thomas More Hawkinson la demande
de révision a été refusée
la raison n'était pas à cause de l'a  busers
mental Andy can cette raison n'avait
été donnée que verbalement ce qui d'ailleurs
ne devrait pas empêcher le dépôt d'accusations
ce qui a été considéré était le jeune
âge de votre fils sa difficulté à raconter les faits
et sa confusion face aux événements
sur Yasur que je ne connaissais pas avant  Je suis un
peuple composite qui lui livre plus de
matière dans une boîte hola de santa clara
Salima me dit pas d'oignon pas de mascara poly
six d'accord Polly Polly Polly Polly Polly
connaissait le paquebot Conan et j'ai trouvé que ce
n'est pas le Palin accessible de longues
semaines  il est vrai que le seul policier
qui a une formation pour traiter les
plaintes d'agression sexuelle ne parle pas en vous
et elle dit qu'il ne lui a pas permis d'être
là lors de l'interrogatoire le médecin urgentiste
qui a examiné le fils de Jenny a noté qu'un enfant
était clair qu'il lui a dit  qui l'a abusé et ce qui lui
avait été fait, elle a noté
tous les détails, ils sont trop dérangeants
pour être répétés ici après le dernier
kit de viol, nos recherches montrent l'hôpital et se sont
dirigés vers le beli indigène  efs
le jour même a été pris mais la police n'a jamais
envoyé au laboratoire du crime à Montréal
en conséquence aucun test n'a été effectué notre
tentative de parler à la police à ce
sujet est restée sans réponse gardien
associé très détaillé allons débarquer
Alice sans savoir de Susie  l'
équipe de fils de concierge a déjà donné que vous savez ce que sur les
commandes de machine l'homme veut concourir
était vraiment une personne vous êtes toujours un Samana
et
les services sociaux de Palma Cruiser ne répondront pas à nos
questions non plus l'épinéphrine manque d'abus
sur la peur
c'est bon de voir un singe une larve recevoir de l'
aide au  bukuvu heureusement sur une
demande écrite aux services sociaux et la
police a été transféré au
bureau d'interdiction après des quantités d'
effet d'obscénité deux fois le chef du groupe
annulé a dit qu'il nous rencontrerait pour
faire les nouvelles locales d'Hollywood eoghankelly
la merde de mamelon deux fois il ne s'est jamais présenté
sans explication nous sommes allés rencontrer les
parents adolescents l'ancienne baby
-sitter et son mari Rajeshwari et jusqu'à
nouveau ils nous ont montré  un
tribunal pour adolescents a ordonné des services à l'
enfance concernant des problèmes signalés concernant leur fils une autre
famille irakienne a pris le coca Astana
à bientôt Italie Sous-comité d'identité anglais et non de Remus pensez-vous que la collaboration de Nana est destinée à la
série kapalama Elantra a marché sur du
cuir est d'aquarium physique
normal  à votre thé de compost animal seulement
Kayla je vais donner pour obtenir le feu et
le moteur de bébé en mode magique ouais Maury montrez-
leur et encouragez à ne rien toucher de plus ont
dit les parents l'adolescent a été
suivi par les services de l'enfance jusqu'à ce qu'il
ait 18 ans quelques mois plus tard  tous
ces éléments sont troublants mais le
bureau du procureur refuse de commenter
mais lorsqu'il a été mis au courant, le
ministère de la sécurité publique du québec a déclenché une
enquête policière sur les maux de tête
Joey Olivia une note clé importante sur pour
une charge d'excuses fam être en août
qualcomm pada puja soutien Asianet
rançon jalapenos
[Musique  ]
nous vivons avril 2016
la police indigène est à nouveau à l'
honneur dans des situations similaires  BTB région de
Québec un policier tue un
autochtone lors d'un appel deux mois
avant qu'un policier soit tué
le corps policier est démantelé
maquillage dans la même région centre
et obg une intimité avait également été
brisée à chaque fois que la cigale Québec
la SQ prend le relais  à Great Scott
cette seule langue des forces de police indigènes en
raison du manque de fonds
et de personnel manque de moyens et aussi de
formation qui compromet juste s'asseoir pour
les femmes indigènes la police locale a répondu
directement au conseil de bande les rendant
ouverts aux manœuvres politiques
pâtes de division homogène
pension alimentaire considérable -  ta mère a été
policière pendant 16 ans et onze de plus en tant
que chef de culte de la police Minuten sur
Richwood une maman elfique Dino
cet été autour de la politique, y compris
il dit que le conseil de bande l'a forcé à
renvoyer son assistant megistus a nos
e-mails soulignant les accusations  oh
quel plaisir distribution
il sait que les policiers ont peur de perdre leur
boulot en prenant un co  plainte contre le chef
est hasardeuse dans les savons de bar le
soutien politique au point est vous voyez 12 1980
papel avant de commencer je vais confisquer
notre Infiniti deuxième élevant la
police de Canela il a mis en place un total de clients népalais une
partie de l'ordre du mérite et politique une
partie de la  Le mérite et la police sentent la
peur que je suis l'esprit produit un ancien
officier du QG Murphy Stacy a une longue
expérience avec les communautés indigènes
népalaises adoptent des affaires d'éternité de téléphone portable
après que la communauté et la violence
contiennent des échantillons mm contenus parmi les
mères Yamazaki va être un
site de sélection site de détournement de fonds un site médical
etc vigile a annoncé un impressionnant rencontré
reporta que la razón possible ma soutien le
plus bas a voir si le chef d'une
force de police oubliée la police américaine
il a dirigé le fu 1977 pour diriger un
moteur de politique IAD d'autres pays de mon
analyse initiale de confiance avec une
obsession de groupe  c'est une force régionale pour toutes
les communautés autochtones sauf les Inuits
une force qui a d'abord été financée par la
federa  l gouvernement
alors à la fois par Québec et Arwa kalamata
Valley végétal cher juste un temps pitarrio
ressource
- aujourd'hui n'est pas Reggio un autre mot d'accord
maire contrôle mes envies jeune fils de
planche époxy dinosaures expulsé contrôle
chef Ella polio titania hôpital dans un
avion casino miles pas d'écurie wadd
tanpopo  micronet multiples anomalies
Arcadia Park on consider DD konavle a
contender textarea Falacci la
police américaine a disparu en l'an 2000
battue par un manque de fonds et
selon cette même pression de vous
aimeriez un oTCQB anglais un transfuge sont bons
sur une certaine
pom-pom girl de désordre communautaire  pour le sommelier et
interpoler ou savoir qui peut dégager de
notre sortie sortie sortie c'est donner sa
capacité à Québec livraison à Cepeda
hétéroclite au hibachi totty totty party
à la fête
allez Victor
fais ça
24h32 un pour le hodo ironiquement avec
le SU  prendre le contrôle des coûts
a explosé et le gouvernement du Québec s'est retrouvé
coincé à retenir la facture un certain jour la
plupart du temps  récemment, vous aviez dit un exemple
tout aussi merdique libéral ouais eh bien c'était
euh c'était un pinceau de gâteau milani de la serda
après un million de twas un repas je pourrais être
quelqu'un de policier sur une
présence de soutien communautaire et depuis à propos du meketa
Patrick sur le dos Elio De  La Rue
Quebec PCD Kuen on en tout dans les nouvelles
communautés où le SU a pris en charge le
coût a triplé les mêmes choses dans le bord
peut être la communauté d'un grand quand ils
démantèlent leur force de police par manque
de fonds et vous ne pouvez pas révéler le SQ
cos  nous sommes cent mille dollars par
semaine deux fois plus que les
croyances indigènes les Anglais et le décret ont
mis en place leurs propres forces de police régionales à
cause de la manière James je dessine
des accords de développement d'autres communautés
ont des forces de police indigènes locales
qui répondent au conseil d'interdiction  et
les forces de police sous-financées, c'est le cas
ici dans le Vermont, elle veut du
matériel de torréfaction de dinde larve de polka en otage en ce que
ma sœur est décédée sont sur un coût de la
technologie de silicium politique  nologie n le chef
nous emmène au poste de police pour que nous puissions
voir par
nous-mêmes c'est RPG le chef de la police abandonne
la tournée Smallville Cecille une prophétie
de survie noire
nous allons vraiment je sais qu'il est temps de faire un
toss the bottom in the Apache war
oh non la serda Pedro es se queda Larkins
pour le président anacondas celerity
préparez-vous savoir ce qui était un
communicateur de type effrayant avant de connaître le nom du
comité ayant un sujet difficile pour le
nikon dispersible l'
ancien chef de la police n'était pas maman était est
retourné à l'école pour obtenir un  diplôme en droit,
dit-il, l'art policier autochtone est aussi bien
formé que les autres policiers en raison du
manque de ressources. systèmes immunitaires spécifiques
un laissez-passer gratuit peut récupérer la
formation que vous pouvez à un moment donné c'est une
communauté bidon devenir un policier
qui veut une formation pour enquêter sur les
agressions sexuelles  payer le double des frais pour assister à
l'académie de police de Québec ou normalement
huit mille dollars pour les
étudiants autochtones c'est trois fois plus 27 000
cette année pas de s autochtones  étudiant s'est
inscrit à l'académie cela coûte plus cher
parce que les forces de police autochtones ne
contribuent pas au financement des académies
contrairement à d'autres polices du québec il y a
un tel manque d'agents autochtones que la
police doit souvent embaucher des non-autochtones
qui ne parlent pas la langue ou ne la connaissent pas  la
culture et ils ne sont pas toujours en tête de
la classe
mr.  Supercentre différent dit singe est
une ville de dossier osseux comme le cinquième québec
sauf à aucun dr Dippolito.  Jasper Jasper
donc
Johnny Johnny était sur l'avortement mon nom
Nova Stassi essaie de reconstruire la
police pour la congestion de l'indentation
Galante et Castle vont prendre
un coup BJ nous un moine animal sauvage désirable
et toutes les femmes qui osent
nous parler ouvertement l'ont fait pour  protéger les enfants
pour briser le cercle vicieux de la maltraitance
d'une génération à l'autre
depuis le pensionnat on est allé voir
Jenny qui s'est réfugiée chez sa
mère trois générations d'e nouvelle
contrôlée positivisme
- McConnell un nouveau visage sur Katya a rencontré la
fille de Mary Polly katawaga  fou fou un
bloc solide même avec Donovan ventaja -
le sais totalement Alma occupé Tomas en
osier monstrovia
Thomas - del Este alors soyez un juge voyez
la loi extrusive de Cal Poly vous l'avez lu vous
savez les cierges magiques et la pièce claire
faucon li l
kanji partenaire G obtenez le  même cash back
off soigneusement livres et Mahesh Babu kana
seulement ces 1260 circuits précis
Bochy
[Musique]